all right first full series for the 12th
doctor
let's see how he did
[Music]
it's that time folks series eight take
two doctor who reviews are
done which means i gotta rank these
cause that's uh
that's what i do i'm a geek i can't stop
myself
so um even though i uh did
the review for each part each half of a
two-parter separately i am going to lump
them together
for this ranking now there's only one
two-parter that that ends up happening
to
but uh that means that we have 11 of
these
to get through so let us begin
at the very bottom
number 11 kill the moon
this thing is just confused not
confusing
confused it either had a point that it
was trying to make
and made it poorly or it accidentally
stumbled and backdoored its way into a
point that a lot of people read into it
that it wasn't trying to make
it's a failing either way either it
presented a story that works
so well as an allegory that everyone
assumed it was and
nobody on the production side caught
that they'd done that
or it was in fact meant as an allegory
in which case it just did not work at
all
and then this thing also has some of the
softest science that doctor who has ever
indulged in and i can be pretty
forgiving about that
but when the moon falls apart and is
then replaced by an identical moon
laid by a dragon who was inside the moon
i'm sorry i'm just gonna go
what number ten
[Music]
the caretaker just uh
a lot of things that don't work for me
in this one pretty much across the board
i don't
the vibe and the humor it's got kind of
a romantic comedy thing going for it
with the way that
uh danny and clara's dynamic is working
in this episode of the way the doctor
kind of stumbles into it and there's the
misunderstandings about
who he thinks clara was dating i'm like
oh god i just don't care
so there's that and i actually like the
relationship between
clara and danny so it's not the that
time spent on the relationship it's the
way it's presented in this
i don't like the blitzer i don't think
is a particularly
interesting antagonistic force either
conceptually or design wise and the
execution of how it moved
was weird and wonky and there just isn't
a lot to recommend this one
number nine in the forest of the night
i suspect a lot of people would have put
this below the caretaker i think the
difference for me is it's hard for me to
get worked up about this episode
because i'm largely just befuddled by it
i honestly don't really know what it was
going for
and so it makes it harder for me to
judge it may well have failed harder
than other things and it certainly
failed in terms of communicating its
intentions if i can
re-watch it this many years later
with as much of a better understanding
about
narratives and themings and all this
other stuff and still go i don't know
what you were doing
with that so obviously it still fails
but because i don't know what it was
doing i can't go
well you failed at what you tried to do
because i can't make heads or tails of
what this thing's trying to do
it's not good but i'm too confused by it
to get upset
number eight into the dalek
basically a mashup honestly thinking
about it now this feels a bit
fanfic-y not in the way that it's like
fan service and that way but i mean
the way that it's basically mashing up
at least three ideas done
before in other episodes into this thing
and not
really doing anything to change them
just sticking all these
these ideas together the ideas of being
miniaturized and being in a mechanical
body that has antibodies
the idea of uh dalek who gets a better
perspective on the daleks and believes
they must be destroyed
the doctor uh you know with his whole
relating to daleks in a way that he
doesn't want to all these are things
done in better episodes and yet they're
all here
mashed up not incompetently mashed up
but just needlessly mashed up
we didn't gain anything from this number
seven
listen there's some great moments and
listen
mostly on the part of capaldi he has
some great speeches some great monologue
moments and he delivers
the heck out of them but
ultimately i just feel like this thing
is spinning circles
i feel like it was a terrific premise
invented
that they just didn't come up with a
firm idea of
what to do with it either in terms of
theming that would lead and mix into the
overall
show or what it said about the
characters
it is presented with this momentousness
that it doesn't
measure up to it's not bad i just find
it frustrating
number six time
heist so we start getting into the ones
that you know
i don't love but i'm like that's fine
nothing really wrong with that but it's
it's fine and that's yeah that's pretty
much time heist
i'm a sucker for a heist but the fact
that this didn't
rank higher for me based on the fact
that i am a sucker for that kind of
stuff
really should kind of tell you a few
things but you know it still has the
things i like about a heist it has the
planning it has the dynamic of the
people working together
it has the tension of oh my gosh are
they going to get caught it's got all
that
it does have some neat twists towards
the end so it's it's
solid number five
deep breath the first full story
for peter capaldi's 12th doctor
and it's pretty good that's that's kind
of it it's pretty good it
there again there are moments that are
really good and i'm not sure there's
anything
in it that is that much better than an
in an episode like say listen
but there are way fewer things pulling
it back down then something like listen
had
capaldi's still giving a very good
performance i am a sucker for the
paternoster gang
although i've said in the past they are
better than most of the stories they've
actually been used in
but i do enjoy them and they worked well
so that
i was on board for had fun with them and
there are some interesting moments and
it plays up the fact that we don't
really know this doctor yet and we don't
know how he's going to react and respond
to things and it does a pretty good job
of playing off that
uncertainty for some decent moments
number four flatline
this is just really good solid stuff
it's such a bizarre premise this whole
idea of these two-dimensional beings
coming into our world and
taking us apart learning about us and
then
trying to become three-dimensional and
add that with the ridiculous idea of the
tardis now being like this little tiny
thing that clara puts in her
purse and the doctor's stuck inside it
because from his end the door keeps
shrinking
yeah it's it's ridiculous and yet also
pretty determined to be unsettling and
unnerving and it
manages to do both in a way that doesn't
clash
all things told yeah it's good work
number three the one i am going to be
accused of putting
way too high for most people's taste but
i told you in the review
i am just a sucker for this thing i have
so much fun with it
and sometimes fun wins robot of
surewood oh i just have so much fun
i love the banter i love the way
that robin gets under the doctor's skin
i love the uh the sort of teacher energy
that clara brings to just get the doctor
to shut up
or tries to at a few points there's just
a really fun dynamic to it
i honestly think we learn a fair bit
about the doctor through
what he thinks of robin and that little
interaction they have towards the end
especially
i i think this is an underrated episode
i'll just say that
number two dark water
and death in heaven you know the more i
think about it the more i think this is
one of the stronger finales
for doctor who i cannot remember where i
put it
when i did my ranking of series finales
a year or two back um if it wasn't
like top three or top four
at a stretch then i underestimated it
but
it's good it's really good it does a
really good job with the reveal
of the cybermen then the reveal of missy
the tension around danny are they going
to be able to get him back and the
payoff of that with the
with his disobeying of everything that
he is supposed to be doing and of course
missy i do love me some missy and
i think it's a really strong closer
especially for a two-parter
oftentimes two-parters one half will be
notably stronger than the other that's
not the case here these are
both equally good episodes good stuff
number one spot could only ever be one
thing
the mummy on the orient express
this for me is the
peak of this season this series
has a lot of roughness let's be honest
if you were paying attention
it wasn't until like the sixth one where
i said they were even just got to
okay prior to that i had frustrations so
that's like
half the episodes i'm like to some
degree or other
but man i love everything about this
episode
i love the tension i love the clock i
love the way the doctor is
bouncing off of everybody and how when
he knows someone's gonna die he doesn't
even bother trying to comfort them
he just accepts that they're gonna die i
love the
scene towards the end where there's the
scene
you know with clara and the doctor and
claire's like is this an addiction and
the doctor says
you really don't know until you try and
quit their interactions are great
there's a great melancholy to it at the
start
when it's believed that this is going to
be their final adventure together
the supporting cast is great the look
for the foretold is great
they actually integrate the soldier
thing that was recurring across the
series
well into the story instead of just
hitting you over the head with
the doctor doesn't like soldiers it's
just it's just the
highest level execution of pretty much
everything this series was trying to do
wrapped up into one awesome shambling
package
so that's my ranking for series six of
doctor who
what do you think whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it you know all the
stuff to do like and subscribe
i've got merch i feel like you don't
plug that very much
though i do have to be honest the
patreon is
the uh the big thing that is what is
currently
uh covering my bills but i also i'm not
trying to guilt anyone and i'm not
trying to pressure you because at the
end of the day
you are the council and i am just
running the meetings
and until next time this council is
[Music]
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]